We began this course with a discussion of the critical problem of chronic disease.
We learned that it accounts for most US health care costs and that
the design of our health care system is not well suited to chronic disease management.
To correct this, we discussed the need for new care models,
better design for the management of these diseases.
We also discussed the critical role that patient behaviors
play in the development of chronic disease and in its successful management.
Finally, provider reimbursements in
the new care and payment models we discussed earlier in
the course are usually based on care quality and clinical outcome metrics.
In the next segment,
we will see that Population Health began in response to the need of
providers to understand and improve their performance against these metrics.
Like public health, it is an important use case for
interoperability since individual providers in some network or
system that is contracted to deliver
cost effective outcomes will usually have different EHR's.
Finally, we will also learn that like virtually all other domains of Health Informatics,
population health is increasingly employing
analytic technologies to predict and proactively manage clinical results.